e dopo tutti i tentativi di furto
incredibilmente riusciti cazzo il
miglior ladro del mondo torna a fare il
colpo più grosso il furto del diamante
sono ritornato porca [ __ ] hard la
difficoltà che significa che ce
l'abbiamo nel culo bene il furto del
diamante ragazzi ci siamo prima di
cominciare facendo sì che questo quasi a
un video bello e da tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj e oggi
siamo su slate iv episodio 3 che
dovrebbe essere in teoria l'ultimo
perché adesso ruberemo il diamante che è
custodito in questa ho fatto un cazzo
non ho fatto già mi sta sparando pieghe
mista sporco del touch in e tu mar mi
scusi lei no io ho parcheggiato la
macchina qua non c'è chi trova fatto di
essere hai bisogno di un milione di
dollari fiume e ho capito come fare in
volta mi sono fatto aveva affanculo
allora la vedo già che c'è una trappola
non so ragazzi dove che sta minchia di
diamante non ne ho idea però vediamo di
riuscire a prenderlo tutti calmi fa
raggiunse riesco provare una tattica di
entrata in casa ma cazzo
no si è pagato verda ho fatto una cosa
bellissima per scavalcare dal retro
porca eva a [ __ ] a place at level ero
praticamente riuscito a entrare sul
retro questa cosa fa min attimo ho
pensato incredibile
chi ha o non riesce a saltare mania
mongoloide va anch'io da bambino ci
riuscivo perfetto
ragazzi niente da fare proviamo un
approccio più normale visto che non ho
visto l'entrata dall'altra parte
[ __ ] suo metodo di entrata che
proverò dopo nel caso non ci riesco
ma io lo so io lo sapevo niente ragazzi
era semplicemente per capire se si
poteva scavalca così era curiosità mia
adesso che siamo sul tetto c'è un tizio
che non credo ma si sa i cadeaux tipo in
testa lo schiaccia dai ci prova a
[ __ ] lo schiaccio lo schiaccio marca
[ __ ] il fatto che io sono solo essendo
io magro quando giocando sulle persone
le persone non sentono
te lo infilo ce l'ho fatta non so cosa
va bene
vabbè primo step è riuscito perfetto
adesso non resta solo che trovare il
diamante ne vedo che ben ben custodito
qua dentro c'è piano di guardie media
prendere per il culo deduco che sia
anche qui il sesto diamante a bonn e
mappatura pensavo ci mettesse di più ad
arrivare va beh attraverso la finestra
non mi vedeva bene posso fare una
domanda come che lui passa in mezzo alla
trappola e non si fa niente qual è il
tuo problema zio ture ok qua c'è la
trappola questa la schivo se io
riuscissi a perché sono vivo impossibile
la voce parte deve essere stoccati degli
amanti e cerchiamo che vengono sia nelle
scatole perché sei un diamante dubito
che sia veramente sono ok va solo 180
mila dollari cosa me ne faccio con prole
goleador con questi ho bisogno del
diamante potente porca [ __ ] i quali
carico veloce forse non riesce a
prendermi il tempo dove vado e qui non
cerchio adige e vabbè marca [ __ ] ce
lo faccio la faccio non ci credo
fermi a donare un codice un codice un co
datemi un cazzo di cane va beh ci sono
va bene se non mi muovo il culo muoio
perfetto qualche altro raiola c'è ci
sarà un codice la vuoi che parla
documenti di banca non mi interessa
voglio il diamante dove studia eccolo
perfetto 86 47 io riuscissi a ad
aggirare che uno stronzo che in teoria
dovrebbe sbucare dalla porta da un
momento all'altro il colera
mi ricordo più l'alzheimer da 8 6 4 7 6
8 6 4 6 3 carico riprendiamo tutto nel
frattemo di chi resta a casa si sa se va
bene
ovviamente poi chiediamoci dove cazzo se
le infila ste cose nelle mutande i
ragazzi in tutto sto bordello il tipo
non è uscito e cioè non so perché
la posta porca eva come faccio a girarlo
passare sotto il tavolo si riesca su chi
le balle per la ricarica scafo appena
ricarica ed alle gare che vai forquet ma
quanti colpi già star ma [ __ ]
ciò è fatta solo vivo oddio 23 per cento
veloce veloce 82 82 qualcuno mi ricordo
più 8 6 6 3 2 ma 8236 non mi ricorda 3 6
no rega veramente 883 26 regalo mi
ricordo ciò alzheimer come cazzo fatta
dimenticarne la solo un [ __ ] 23 se
io thai non posso tornare lineare mazza
263 2888 iniziarono 82 82 63
ma che cosa c'è che non va
lo faccio alla fermo scopo il video
stoppa do riavvio il video riavviato
bene adesso esco ciao amici che bello
che se vado a vedere il video registrato
voglio vedere che cazzo c'è la scritta
che non posso tornare lì che l'alzheimer
barca a vela di all alzheimer a 21 anni
minchiata 86 47 il 2 e il 3 dove cazzo
li ho visti o 8 6 4 6 8 6
vi rendete conto cosa cazzo dovuto fare
per rivedere sta minchia di codice va
bene è veloce veloce e chiudi veloce ea
madonna negli inferi dormicchia stiamo
andare cos'è eccolo ci siamo ragazzi ci
siamo non apre
non è che no ma non può arrivare
non ci credo perché allora devo capire
come come faccio qua sotto
aiuto lo trovate due cazzo va di qua
veloce che cazzo ci faceva altra gente
qui sotto perché c'è altra gente ma dava
affanculo migliori far tutto vero che
almeno diamante valga un milione perché
non c'ho voglia di riprendermi tutti i
computer e sta minkia 86 47 86 47 veloce
ma cosa no ma come no kat l'abbia presa
scemo ha bevuto vero ma è ubriaco 864
qualche cosa vuoi di più
sono scrivere e adesso dove cazzo e
cambia anche la posizione ma siamo seri
53 42 ma perché lei cambiamo ardeva
lasciano aperta 53 42 53 42 ma come ha
fatto a prenderli in quanto ci metti a
cadere al 53 vabbè ormai non posso
perché ha cambiato di nuovo posizione
[ __ ] se morisse tua sorella veloce
veloce veloce veloce 86 47 86 47 no 5
342 sì veloce porca [ __ ] corride
fitch e allora fatemi capire come lo
prendo sto coso dispiace devo no devo
scrivere che devo fare altre cose che
non ho capito però che vediamo poi c'è
una trappola
l'affetto allora devo far diventare quei
cosi verdi propria è la madonna non è
questo però le dobbiamo muoverci perché
arriva gente ok perfetto
ogni stanza è utilissima devo far
diventare quei così probabilmente verdi
ma non ho capito come ma che cazzo ci
faccio qui
eva certo ma non avevo dubbi se si
uniscono sui due deficienti almeno è
successo ma 20 l'arca [ __ ] veloce
veloce veloce veloce se mi seguono tutti
e due in teoria dovrei poter entrare
fetto
la ragazza non mi ha visto
stavo scherzando mi ha visto che sta
facendo voi due
cosa fa quello scemo cazzo che ha visto
il garri 83 86 47 primo le funzioni non
sempre 50 per cento beccato con lo
sbagliato mtdh la volta in cui ci
azzecco li mortacci mia
porca [ __ ] e 86 47 vai a grazia di
dio non farcela allora ripartiamo in
questo punto visto che fin qua ci siamo
arrivati e va beh come faccio a
superarlo questo mi spiegate ragazzi ci
sarà un mondo e vabbè quanti siete
tanta gente mica un party mi serve un
arma come faccia ce l'avete un'arma di
merda da qualche parte chi serve un arma
rega come faccio sempre
e di questo che sto parlando picchiano
lavora lavorista mai nella vita va mica
potevate dirmelo prima
la capitana ce lo fa non ci posso
credere
prendi quel [ __ ] a capo e sparagna
nel tuo allora 55 42 anni [ __ ] anche
incredibile non mi ricordo le cose non
pro neanche a sparare a vetro perché
sicuro non serve a un cazzo quindi va
bene così
allora piano mi chiamo bisogni traglio
la famiglia
quell'altro chicca cosa dove cosa ma chi
cazzo mi stava sparando prima devo farlo
spiega mio non muore
quanta gente è un party è un party o
amiche incredibile come morto poi piano
mica tre guardie c'è pazzesco suo gioco
ma da qualche parte dovrà attivare quei
codici si attiverà piano dopo eccolo per
far ho trovato un interruttore ragazzi
fermi
c'è un interruttore è che cazzo attivato
spero che si sia ora che ci sono dei
buchi di proiettile sullo schermo che
cosa sa ci sono tutte le leve ce ne sono
cinque allora sicuro senza neanche
controllare sono sicuro che soci in
color 2 interrogassimo se muoio
e vabbè cos'è sta roba se muoiono riesco
mai più nella vita a rifare quello che
ho fatto ve lo dico è mai più nella vita
riesco però ne ho due o perfetto 3
incredibile 4 e la quinta do ragazzo sta
bene manca una porca eva lo sapevo io
morisse cugino apriti frate è la
provenza indicarsi non c'è niente a
parte i lingotti non c'era niente trovo
ragazzi non la trovo caccia eva non
l'avevo vista mai veloce prima gara
vigente che allarmato tutto qua e lupin
può accompagnare solo allora fermi e qua
la situazione tragica do tornare alla
macchina mi piace pensate se muoio
adesso che escono ma veramente lancio
con più vi giuro lancio il computer non
ce la posso fare
servirvi insegne ammazzano lancio non
tornerò mai più nella vita qui
dove sono quei [ __ ]
non lo so minacce però velocissimo
nell'altro lazio la lazio non ci credo
non ci credo mai non ci credo mai nella
vita
dovete morire 18 anni per fare il suo
livello ma ce l'ho fatta va bene così
ragazzi miei è stato wow ma proprio
bello bello bello scoperto che ci sono i
livelli della community
perché c'è chi ha speso tempo a fare dei
livelli pure va bene niente ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto spero che
avete capito come rubare un diamante da
un milione di dollari perché zio fa vivi
insegna le cose le cose giuste ai
cassoni miei spero che vi sia piaciuto
cose insieme misure sul momento è un mi
piace ai già facendo facebook.com
tiziano si sono estinti scandali ci
picchiavano possiamo vita della ragazza
[Musica]